une crise migratoire doublée d'une crise
diplomatique dans laquelle chaque partie
accusé l'autre d'être responsable
dernière déclaration en date celle du
premier ministre polonais qui récuse la
biélorussie je cite de terrorisme d'état
échanges téléphoniques également ce
matin entre angela merkel et vladimir
poutine la chancelière allemande demande
au président russe de réagir et jugent
inacceptables
l'instrumentalisation des migrants par
la biélorussie son chef de la diplomatie
comme à ses débuts favorable à de
nouvelles sanctions de l'union
européenne contre minsk qui l'accusent
d'exploiter les réfugiés le kremlin pour
sa part jugé responsable accusé moscou
d'être à l'origine de cette crise le
ministre russe des affaires étrangères a
d'ailleurs tenu une conférence de presse
commune avec son homologue biélorusse ce
matin les précisions de notre
correspondante en russie verhaeghe
hoffman envoyé des milliers de
militaires face à des femmes et des
enfants réfugiés est une violation de
toutes les normes imaginables a déclaré
le ministre des affaires étrangères de
la bielle a aussi vladimir mcee lors
d'une conférence de presse conjointe ce
mercredi avec son homologue russe
sergueï lavrov l'admirent mac est
également pointé du doigt l'hypocrisie
de l'union européenne qui acceptent les
migrants qui arrivent sur son sol via la
méditerranée où les balkans mais emploie
la force contre ce qui transite par la
biélorussie écoutez cette politique sain
cerveau d'un nombre de dirigeants des
pays occidentaux est devenue la norme
aujourd'hui ils n'essaient même pas de
compte et la situation
il ne voit pas dans l'avenir la plus
proche les ligneurs les choses
principalement temps en faisant sortir
12000 et 15000 déjà un militaire
contre les migrants à 1 contre les
femmes et les enfants qui pleurent et ne
pas ne les laissant pas entrer en europe
où ils cherchent tellement à venir
pour moi c'est une situation impossible
à imaginer c'est la violation de toutes
les normes imaginables et en plus ils
nous accusent d'organiser ces flux mais
ça n'a rien à voir avec la réalité
pourquoi
il y a des balkans il ya la méditerranée
il y à des migrants qui
reçoivent
des privilèges et une protection donc
les migrants qui premier qui viennent de
ces décès et de ces endroits auxquels la
berlue si c'est ça pose problème quant
au chef de la diplomatie russe sergueï
lavrov et l'a évoqué le rôle de la
russie dans la crise migratoire
répondant ainsi au premier ministre aux
polonais qui accusait vladimir poutine
d'être coresponsables de cette situation
qualifiée par varsovie d'attac une bride
écoutez nous n'avons pas reçu de
demandes ni des polos n'a dit ni des
lituaniens à propos de d'un éventuel
rôle de médiation dans cette discussion
je pense qu'ils n'ont rien demandé mais
il cherche simplement imposer leur
importance en faisant des déclarations
de ce type
accusant la biélorussie et du même coup
la russie d'être à l'origine de ces
événements et je considère que c'est une
nouvelle fois une manifestation de ce
que nous venons dire c'est à dire une
manifestation de ce complexe de
supériorité du complexe de grandeur
d'impunité dans toutes les questions
plusieurs milliers de migrants
principalement originaires du
moyen-orient est arrivé avec un visa
biélorusse pour rejoindre l'union
européenne se trouve depuis maintenant
trois jours face à une frontière
polonaise hérissée de barbelés et gardé
par des milliers de militaires polonais